[Applaudissements]
2 les chars pas l'organisation caddie
baradji repère une dernière fois les
locaux du sdsl center à maurepas le 29
décembre prochain 20 athlètes vont
transpirer pour devenir miss et mister
fitness france 2022 c'est une
compétition et pas un concours c'est
très important en fait c'est une
compétition tout simplement parce que
tous ceux qui évaluent et ce jour là
c'est la performance donc c'est le
maximum qu'on est capable de faire là la
résistance qu'on a la force qu'on a
le courage et la détermination à faire
des épreuves et non pas non pas le
physique qui est pris en compte une
partie des mille mètres carrés du
complexe sportif norvégien sera dédiée à
la compétition venus de toute la france
les concurrents sont attendus sur
plusieurs épreuves coach pratique en
salle ou seulement passionné 2 fitness
leurs profils sont nombreux il faut
avoir la capacité à faire déjà des
tractions ça c'est super important des
pompes être bon au poids de corps et
surtout il faut avoir un profil complet
il faut être aussi bon en exercices
cardiovasculaires quand musculation
c'est la première fois que la
compétition est organisée dans les
yvelines les places sont disponibles sur
la page facebook de l'organisation dans
la tente de l'évolution sanitaire